je m'appelle Rada Hatem je suis
gynécologue à coucheur et j'ai fondé la
Maison des Femmes en 2016 dans ma
pratique et donc notamment dans cette
maison des femmes
c'est un accueil inconditionnel pour
toutes les femmes vulnérables et
victimes de violences on les reçoit on
les soigne on soigne leur corps on
soigne leur psyché on essaie de les
aider sur le plan social juridique
économique
mon expérience de médecin un peu engagé
dans le droit des femmes et notamment
tout ce qui concerne leurs droits à
disposer de leur corps puisque en tant
que gynécologue se sont nos sujets
pouvaient intéresser ces étudiants qui
sont majoritairement des étudiants en
droit et effectivement il y a une grande
corrélation entre médecine et droit
notamment sur ces sujets
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps est en droit assez récent qu'il
est encore assez fragile questionné dans
beaucoup d'endroits de la planète on a
de la chance en France les mouvements
féministes ont des marées il y a plus de
100 ans et alors ils ont été inégaux ils
sont variables il y a un million de
façon d'être féministes mais ce qui est
certain c'est que si ça n'avait pas
commencé il y a 100 ans on en serait pas
là aujourd'hui il y a eu énormément
d'acquis ces 100 dernières années alors
que pendant des millénaires la culture
patriarcale était la culture dominante
aujourd'hui elle est questionnée alors
peut-être que le balancier va aller un
petit peu trop loin c'est normal
j'espère qu'on va surtout trouver un
équilibre et que cette nouvelle
génération sera celle de cet équilibre
[Musique]